en Barcelona los resultados de los
comicios de anoche también fueron muy
decepcionantes para la izquierda Xavier
Díaz el candidato nacionalista Catalán
de centro de gecha ganó estas
municipales con un 22% de los votos 11
concejales pero podría no ser alcalde
finalmente si las izquierdas se unen y
esto al menos es el deseo de adakolaula
alcaldesa actual candidata de la
izquierda alternativa Quién hizo un
llamamiento anoche a la unión de las
fuerzas progresistas con los socialistas
que sacaban 10 concejales segunda fuerza
ella y su partido 9 concejales y la
izquierda independentista que sacó cinco
Barcelona es la única gran ciudad del
estado que podría gobernar la izquierda
eso fue un aviso del portavoz de Colón
que hizo esta misma mañana en los tres
partidos
tienen Ahora hasta el 17 de junio para
pactar pero esta Alianza llega muy
complicada y las figuras políticas de
los tres partidos a nivel nacional
tengan un peso muy importante en estas
negociaciones unas negociaciones que
padecerán un ensayo en general antes de
los comicios de estas elecciones
legislativas adelantadas para el 23 de
julio